Jetons un coup d’œil à l'industrie STIM ?
La science, la technologie, l'ingénierie et les maths.
Elles ont toutes une grande importance dans nos vies quotidiennes.
C'est là précisément qu'on trouve le plafond de verre le plus épais,
et le mieux documenté.
Et si le traitement contre le cancer
ou la solution au réchauffement climatique
était dans l'esprit d'une jeune femme scientifique qui n'a pas pu progresser ?
Cela m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir.
Ça m'a conduit à penser que je devais agir, pas uniquement parler.
J'en ai donc parlé à cette amie merveilleuse
et journaliste brillante, Catherine Mayer.
Avec beaucoup de témérité,
et sans doute autant de vin --
(Rires)
nous avons décidé de fonder un nouveau parti politique.
Car il y a un élément vital :
les urnes sont le seul et unique endroit où les hommes et les femmes sont égaux.
Nous n'avions aucune idée de ce qui nous attendait,
ni combien il est compliqué de créer un parti politique.
Ça ne pouvait pas être si dur.
Après tout, les hommes le font depuis des années.
(Rires)
Au début, on l'a donc appelé : « le Parti pour l’Égalité des Femmes. »
Les gens m'ont demandé immédiatement :
« Pourquoi ce nom-là ? »
J'ai répondu : « Je ne sais pas. Autant annoncer la couleur. »
(Rires)
Je ne voulais pas que notre but soit un secret.
On me disait : « C'est trop féministe. Vous ne pouvez pas le nommer ainsi. »
Oh ! Le vilain mot ! Aaah !
Combien de fois n'ai-je pas entendu quelqu'un dire ceci :
« Je ne suis pas féministe, mais... »
Et je pense systématiquement que s'il y a un « mais »,
c'est que tout n'est pas rose.
On a ensuite commencé à me poser cette question hilarante :
« Allez-vous brûler vos soutiens-gorge ? »
Tout le monde le sait, ils sont fait dans des matières inflammables.
(Rires)
C'est pour ça que les femmes brillent quand elles marchent.
Pour la petite histoire :
aucune femme n'a brûlé son soutien-gorge dans les années 60.
C'est l'invention d'un journaliste.
Heureusement, le journalisme a fait des progrès depuis lors.
Donc --
(Rires)
J'ai annoncé notre projet durant une interview télévisée.
Et les mails ont déferlé immédiatement.
Des centaines, et puis, des milliers.
De tous les âges : des jeunes femmes et des personnes de 90 ans.
Des centaines d'hommes fabuleux.
« Comment puis-je aider ? »
« Peut-on vous rendre visite au siège ? »
On n'avait pas de siège. On n'avait pas encore de parti !
Nous n'avions rien.
Mais nous avions un groupe d'amies formidables
qui tentaient de répondre aux e-mails 24 heures sur 24, en pyjamas.
On était toutes très occupées.
Nous avions une carrière, des enfants.
On a fait ce que les femmes font : on a partagé le boulot.
Directement, on s'est mises d'accord sur des points fondamentaux.
D'abord, nous voulions être le seul parti politique au monde
dont l'objectif serait de ne pas être pérenne.
Quelle idée fantastique !
Nous voulions être le seul parti sans orientation politique.
Nous voulions rassembler ceux de gauche, de droite et du centre,
quel que soit leur âge.
Car nous n'avions qu'un seul objectif dans notre programme :
obtenir l'égalité dans tous les aspects de nos vies
et quand c'est fait,
rentrons à la maison et faisons autre chose.
(Rires)
Nous voulions aussi transformer la politique.
Je ne sais pas chez vous,
mais en Angleterre, il y a deux grands partis.
Ce sont des dinosaures de la politique.
Leurs débats sont embarrassants et envenimés.
Je suis persuadée que vous n'avez pas ça.
(Rires)
Les noms d'oiseaux, les mensonges...
Ce serait quand même formidable si un seul politicien avouait :
« Mon opposant a gagné un point.
Essayons de travailler ensemble et atteindre notre but. »
(Applaudissements)
Accueillons davantage de femmes en politique !
Plus de femmes en politique, immédiatement,
en fondant le seul parti politique qui offre la garderie aux candidates,
pour leur permettre de quitter la maison et faire campagne.
(Applaudissements)
Après 10 mois,
nous avions créé plus de 70 antennes à travers le pays.
On a présenté des candidates aux élections à Londres, en Écosse et au Pays de Galles,
en mai 2016.
1 électeur sur 20 a choisi une de nos candidates à la mairie de Londres.
Et quand les hommes en lice ont constaté combien de voix nous drainions,
le miracle est arrivé,
ils ont commencé à parler de la nécessité de gérer l'égalité des genres.
(Applaudissements)
On m'a promis que ça changerait depuis que je suis petite.
C'était imminent :
les femmes allaient être debout, côte-à-côte avec les hommes.
Je n'ai jamais récolté que promesses et déception.
Suffisamment de déception pour fonder notre parti politique.
Je vais donc vous dévoiler mon idée du jour, mes 5% de nouvelles idées.
C'est une super idée.
Ce n'est pas assez.
Ce n'est pas assez de fonder un parti pour l'égalité dans un seul pays.
On a besoin d'un changement sismique dans le paysage politique mondial.
Notre modèle a ceci de formidable qu'il peut fonctionner n'importe où :
aux États-Unis,
en Australie, en Inde.
C'est la recette parfaite. Tout le monde peut la reproduire.
C'est positif pour tout le monde.
Et on veut la distribuer.
Vous voulez savoir ce qu'on a accompli ? On vous l'offre.
Imaginez que nous parvenions à mobiliser des millions de femmes dans le monde
qui disent : « Assez ! » aux batailles traditionnelles des politiques,
qui disent : « Stop à vos querelles. Agissons maintenant ! »
On pourrait carrément changer le monde.
C'est mon vœu le plus cher.
(Applaudissements)
Je le souhaite...
Je le souhaite pour nos filles
et je le souhaite pour nos fils.
Parce que c'est un fait : l'égalité est meilleure pour tous.
Allons-y ! Agissons ! Changeons le monde !
Je sais qu'on peut le faire. On le mérite !
(Applaudissements)